the day after his shock overwhelming
defeat in primary elections president
Mauricio Macri said he would listen more
he appealed to art and science for
patience for his policies to show
results his address to the nation came
after a day of emergency meetings
firstly with the head of the central
bank then with his cabinet
I mean Diliman do you mater und a muy
Malo we've had a very bad day today
we're poorer than we were before the
primaries we've been hit hard the dollar
has gone up again with all the
consequences that will have the markets
reacted to Sunday's result while the
government was still reeling the
Argentine peso lost 1/3 of its value
against the US dollar in the first few
hours of trading stocks and shares in
both Wall Street and bueno Cyrus took a
pounding the Argentine electorate has
clearly rejected president macri's
neoliberal austerity measures while the
opposition is offering solutions to
Argentina's problems that the financial
markets have clearly said they don't
like if the results of Sunday's
primaries are repeated in October then
it would signal a clear first-round
victory for a Berto Fernandez his vice
presidential running mate is the former
President Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner
and the markets for a return to her
populism high spending on social
projects and the allegations of
corruption that still haunt her it seems
to me the Argentine's haven't learned
much in all these years I think a
hardcore tourism is going to come back
to the government which i think is bad
news equally Macri is a bad manager the
economy a bad manners economy who
applaud a gradualism that didn't work
can't believe the voters prefer Cru a
criminal a mob and they don't appreciate
all the public work that's been done
it's bad I'm mad and I'm sad because
this can't be the result has resounded
across Latin America the right-wing
presidents of neighboring Brazil warned
that the return of a left-wing
government in Argentina could lead to
another Venezuela we don't want our
argentine brothers fleeing here that
would happen if the results of the
elections held yesterday are confirmed
in the october vote
the size of the Argentine government
defeat is still being analyzed there's a
difficult situation the voters votes was
a pocket and the investor votes was runs
with expectation of economic and policy
with a little over two months until
presidential elections the Argentine
electorate must now consider which of
two starkly opposing economic models
will best resolve their dire economic
difficulties dan Shriner al Jazeera won
Osiris